this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to audit.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like pressing code Joey
and get 10 off delivered right to your
house what's happening you bad
[__] it's Monday December 5th
it's a whole new month with a whole new
set of [__] rules get ready Savages
this Saturday UFC 282 is here there's
only one place you could bet like Uncle
Joey DraftKings sports book the official
sports betting part of the UFC they got
a deal for you that's going to make your
pubic hairs [__] crinkle up this
Saturday new customers can bet just five
dollars on a pre-fight money line you
ready five dollars pre-fight money line
on any fight at the win and once they
get the job done you win 150 and free
bets listen I've got Darren till this
week Bryce Mitchell is fighting we got a
tremendous card right now everyone can
earn a 50 boost when you place the same
game parlay and UFC 282 download the app
now use promo code Joey and bet five
dollar pre-fight money line on any
fighter to win the fight if you get 150
if they do that's code Joey this
Saturday at DraftKings Sportsbook the
official sports betting part of the UFC
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details and
listen we got a Monday Night Football
game tonight so you get the party
started tonight let's get this party
started right now though the joint is
here on a Monday morning
foreign
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's Monday the 5th of [__] December
was a great weekend War already and
goddamn [__] December we're in It to
Win It Jack you know like I was watching
oh Sons of Anarchy when the [__] guy
goes I don't want to go to war and he
goes son we already in it you know what
I'm saying like we're already here it's
getting cold and uh it's December that's
it was a great [__] weekend
um
hung out with the girls no comedy I
didn't do dick worked out went to uh
Gracie uh seminar on Saturday got my
blue belt at the [__] promotion
finally I got it the right way I did the
[__] steps I did the classes I don't
really think I'm a blue belt but uh I
went up there with an open mind to be
honest with you guys I'm like I'm not
getting no [__] blue belt today and I
was fine with that I'm just listening
for me in my world I'm an old man I'm
not trying to go to the no ghee worlds
or the worlds or nothing I'm just trying
to get in shape meet new people you know
[__] around a little bit get hurt get
choked out that's it but I'm really
happy you know I tell you guys all the
time that
listen you might not be good at
something a stand up for me what do you
think I [__] got up on the stage and
people were giving me [__] props no
it's a journey and it's sticking with it
that
is so beneficial like anybody could
[__] quit anything anybody
picking with it is what people usually
don't do you know
and again you know I learned from my
mistakes and I try to the mistakes I
really made I always try to correct them
when I first joined jujitsu
I was getting information from
everywhere and it was very confusing for
me my schedule was [__] up there was
weeks I could train I couldn't train and
I didn't think I gave myself a fair
chance I really loved Alberto crane
school where I got my blue buff I love
subconscious but I was always missing
something after I taught my hamstring I
was like that's it I'm not going to be
able to do [__] anymore in fact I gave a
bunch of my Gees away I saved like two
geese and when I got here I got bored
one day and I was just Googling [__] and
I thought there was a great City school
and I went up there and I really liked
what they did I liked the program it was
it wasn't a California type program it
was a a slower more fundamental program
and I went and man I tell you I struggle
I struggle every [__] class but I
show up
and I'm a little older I understand that
I have to give myself a breathing like
you have to when you start Jujitsu to
check your ego at the door which you
should be doing in all aspects of all
your life
but at my age I really got to go in
there and check my ego at the door
there's not much I can do but just
showing up man doing the warm-ups trying
the best you can laughing with people it
makes a world of a difference and if it
gets me a little healthier listen at my
age right now or you keep hearing even
[__] thought look at [__] thought
Thor is like a guy that eats [__]
carrots and lips weights and drinks
[__] carrot juice and [__] and he's
taken six months off because he's got
some gene or something but he's got
dementia you know how much that scares
me you know what I live with right now I
live with my friends telling me about
their parents
how hard it is to [__] I have a
friend right now that he's the sweetest
guy in the world I've known this guy for
[__] 40 years
I mean just a gentleman and his mother
is in hospice you know she doesn't even
know who she is half the time
the father you know it's it's [__]
rough so dementia scares the [__] out of
me like we did cocaine we smoked reefer
for 40 [__] years I got hit in the
head a couple times I'm a little
concerned so
that's why when you get older I like to
do things that involve your mind involve
steps when you do Jiu Jitsu I grab you
let's say it's uh it's a [__] arm bar
from the closed guard I gotta pull your
arm
put my leg on your [__] hip you know
[__] throw this leg over take your
balance off and then push your face away
so my leg could get over those are steps
it's six steps so you have to memorize
those steps and that's that will help me
with dementia when you hit the bag you
do combos right I'm not Muhammad Ali but
you do little combos you break a sweat
all those little uh you know
jab and uppercut left hook [__] the
right cross all that [__] and reputation
and repetition reputation it must it
must [__] help you the [__] out you
know so
this is why I'm into this stuff I know
people always say to me yeah but you do
that guys I'm harmless I can't do
anything I my flying through the head
days have come to a [__] end but just
showing up I can't say this enough to
people
just showing up and guess what some days
you're going to have shitty days you
might have two shitty days you have a
shitty day at the gym you go to the gym
and you're not feeling it and the
weights and but then you go in there
some other days and you're [__]
throwing things around like [__]
thought you're throwing weights around
and people and you know so you have bad
days and good days but the most
important thing is not to give up you
know those guys are Jiu Jitsu what they
always say to me man
and it means the world the other day
when I got the blue belt when I walked
up to Hollis and I was like Alice I'm
not ready for this Legos yes you are he
goes I know the first time you got your
blue boat you think you weren't ready
this time you're ready you're putting in
the work and just keep showing up they
have a multitude of classes you go to
you go to classes and not roll you go to
classes and drill you go to classes and
get killed so
I'm happy I go in there it's uh it's
more of a therapy for me honest to God
the first time I went to jiu jitsu was
the day of the many Saints of Newark
premiere and I was petrified I had a
horrible fear of [__] covet horrible
now I walk into a coveted cave I don't
give a [__] I walk and die it doesn't
matter but guys at first it really
Jarred me the fear and I still remember
him calling me me walking upstairs
to a room
and [__] going like it was just me
and him in the class we're doing a
private Sean who also got his brown belt
yesterday I [__] this is my little
brother this is my son and I love this
little Irishman
he's the one that made me go back in
there and
never forget walking out of there that
first day I'm gonna forget him being in
my closed guard and breathing on me and
me going if I'm not dying by this you
know I don't even want people breathing
on me my back so I wouldn't leave the
[__] house just the fact that I went
there
and didn't when I got up off that mat I
did a horrible job that day I couldn't
even [__] breathe but when I walked
down those stairs I was like this is
what I needed to eliminate that fear and
I got in the car and went right into the
Beacon Theater and I walked down there
was 2 000 [__] people there and I'm
like here we go we're gonna die again
now but I [__] and didn't get covered
the point is that that Jiu Jitsu
eliminated my fear and then three months
later I ended up getting covered in here
we [__] off but
I'm really happy that I [__] walked
in there and
you know a lot of these guys always said
to me Joey we wish we could get our
fathers to come in here
like I like every four classes a guy
will go man I was talking to my wife and
I told you you come in here
and she's like he's a real [__] dude
you know because in L.A guys like me
would take private classes and I don't
want nobody else in the gym and me why
join Jiu Jitsu if you're not going to be
involved with people that's what part of
it is it's human touch it's grabbing
it's pushing and at the end you shake
hands I mean it you laugh your [__]
ass off and it's like my daughter I
watch my daughter my daughter does
basketball she's got a little circle of
friends
I don't know how many times I'll tell my
daughter all right we're going to
kickboxing today we're going to Fat
Joe's and she's like I don't know that
as soon as I walked in the door with her
she's giggling with these [__] kids
because you have a whole new set of
friends over there and now we're gonna
start doing more things at night and
dinners and [__] like that but it's just
a way of life and if you're a little
lost or confused or yeah whatever the
[__] you're going through it might be
the answer there's a kid that I had on
my patreon Kurt mcpeek I love this Kurt
it's a bad [__] Kurt joined Kurt
went up there Kurt told me you think I
should go and I go Kurt curse a little
shy guy very personable he goes up there
he just got a second stripe he [__]
goes to double classes Kurt walks with
Lee on the patreon you know he's just a
sweetheart of a kid and that's a feather
in my cap for me when I see Kurt up
there Colonel hit me on patreon I went
to two classes I'm sore as [__] I can't
walk my eye is sore you know
but he always thank me thank you
thank you for giving me the advice to
come up here it's [__] great the guys
are great
so I'm very happy and like I said to you
if you you're lonely you're [__] out
of shape I mean whatever listen just
join don't tell me that well I need to
get in [__] just join you'll get in
shape as you go and the people will take
care of you more than what the [__] you
think guys people take care in Jiu-Jitsu
oh my God there's certain guys to hold
the belts they'll come over and go don't
do this man don't do this do this don't
let this [__] animal get on top of
you you know so trust me it's a
different [__] world I never thought
I would love this world I mean I'm an
old man I got nothing going for me but I
can go there's a guy that's 69 that
kicks my ass every time I go there's
another guy that's 65 Charlie I'm gonna
go see him he's at Gracie and Long
Branch and all these schools are
connected so you could train at Gracie
Middletown Gracie Old Bridge I'd get in
the car tomorrow and go to Long Branch
or I get in the car tomorrow night and
go to Gracie [__] uh
that's what my daytime teacher is that's
I love that Hargrove
Garland or something like that Garwood
Gracie Garwood so you could train at all
these different schools and guys it's
like next Sunday I got to go to a
[__] uh uh [__] school at long
branches doing that grand opening you
know so this is what you know you go you
talk to people you eat some [__]
Brazilian food you get an acai Bowl you
eat the granola and the fruit and you
call it a [__] night what else has
been going on this week I've been
getting a lot of [__] hits lately
some people goof on me and I I you know
some people call them you know whatever
uh cocaine bear is coming the [__] out
and it's all over the place so people
hit me up listen here it is plain and
simple if you don't believe me even
Michael stick up for me I was the first
person to talk about that cocaine bad
thing and I'll tell you the [__]
story to it before you get all confused
and [__]
I live the Snowmass Village in 84 and
when I went to Aspen in 84 my whole mind
like
when I went to Colorado I was a fiend
already not an addictive feed I was just
a like a little [__] young Coke Fiend
I was 19 and uh
Scarface hadn't come out yet we didn't
even know the basics of cocaine some
people knew it some people didn't I had
grown up with it it was in my mother's
bar I saw it in my house
you know I just kept my mouth shut about
it but when I went to Aspen the first
thing that happened was I got a
the guy who talked me into going to ask
me was Jimmy Burke who got blood rest
his soul but the the guy who convinced
me was my cousin Tweety Tweety's a bad
[__] he's about 68 now
lives in Miami uh
Tweety I just bumped into him one day
after I spoken to Jimmy Burke and I'm
thinking I'm moving to hospital because
I got a house in Aspen I go what
what are you talking about he goes I got
a house in Aspen if you come up come
visit me Maroon Bells all this [__] and
I'm like what do you how does a guy from
West New York
get a house and [__] Aspen and he
goes all the people I work with but I
didn't know who we worked with
I you know whatever so he gave me a
number and uh
whenever I [__] got that Snowmass
Village I lived in Basalt first moved to
school I lived in Basalt I did a little
Coke I had to go to Carbondale to cop it
you know like just a half gram every
other week [__] like that when I moved
to Snowmass there was a lot more cocaine
around now it's 1983 guys
by this point
when I left North Bergen in 83 in April
of 83 cocaine was around
you know people were doing it people had
it you could go into the City and get it
when I went to Aspen when I went to
Snowmass Village Colorado whatever
when I got there you know when I got to
Snowmass Village like I said I was
snorting coke and stuff but I saw that
the coke world was a little thicker out
there
and for people who don't know this and
you're not going to believe what I'm
about to tell you and you could Google
it
when I got to Colorado in 1983 I never
forget one of the first times I went to
Ashland and bought cocaine
and somebody said to me bro you're at
the right place if you like Coke
and I'm like I love cocaine they're like
you're at the right place because
Aspen is the cocaine capital of the
United States I'm like
what the [__] are you talking about it's
Miami and they're like no it's not
because Aspen Gunnison all those places
are the uh
where they store it to go to Minneapolis
Idaho it's Mid Country Denver is
mid-country pretty much and it's a port
you could take it to California you know
Arizona New Mexico so that you know that
was the thinking back then I guess but I
remember I was in a bar called Patty
Bugattis one time and some guy was
telling me that you're at the right
place man you're at the Capitol cocaine
Aspen Colorado the mother of pearl and
I'm like what are you talking about
and I started buying Coke and Aspen and
that [__] was to a different [__]
level that [__] was glass
you know the coke that they were getting
up in there and it was a hundred dollars
sometimes a hundred and ten they were
not [__] around and tight counts I
mean you got a tight [__] gram
but cocaine was everywhere you know I
didn't know any players I love to tell
you I knew Pablo I didn't know anybody
right I knew nothing but I would
hear the different things you know I
became a burglar in Colorado and snow
glass really so I would hear different
things I I always played the guy that
didn't do Coke
if I bought Coke from a dealer it was
from my roommate that worked for vpm he
didn't want nobody no he did Coke so he
didn't want to buy it so everybody
always knew I was a reef ahead and a
[__] weight lifter that had nothing
to do with cocaine they knew I didn't
drink they knew I just smoked pot so
when Coke started missing up in Snowmass
Village
nobody looked at me because they would
go
he don't do Coke he's a [__] pothead
but these guys were all part of a
network okay that I there was a guy
named
I don't know I don't remember what his
name was sweetheart of a guy and there
was a girl named Keels that was a piece
of ass beautiful they got rich right
before my eyes in 83. I got there in
April I moved to Snowmass in June and by
[__] the time I left in January these
guys were driving [__] new cars it
was insane how fast cocaine was moving
but especially up there
foreign
the coke I was getting
an aspen
was way better than anything I was
getting here at the time and we're close
to Union City
Union City is a Cuban [__] Hub Mario
elitos all that [__] when they came in
to the picture cocaine was everywhere
here but when I went to Aspen the
cocaine was a lot better when I got back
from Aspen to New York in February of 84
cocaine was [__] everywhere here but
let's get back to the cocaine bath
so my cousin told me he lived in Maroon
Bells if you Google Maroon Bells it's
[__] beautiful it's like a mountain
it's [__] gorgeous up there and he
told me that he lived next to Jack
Nicholson
and I remember taking a bus up there one
day and going I'm just going to knock on
his door because I kept calling him and
leaving messages call him and leaving
messages and I finally walked up there
one day it was like a [__] two mile
hike going upward and [__] altitude
it's 90 degrees and I went to his house
to bring the door but nobody answered
and next doors were Jack Nicholson lived
and there was a fence there and [__] but
when I walked down from there I
remembered that
God damn I saw a lot of Mercedes and
Porsches and you know this is like a
snow community at that time you saw
Subarus and like Trunks and [__] but
there was all this you know all these
Porsches and [__] I just started hearing
little Rumblings and stuff like that
and on December like 12th the
anniversary is coming
this dude
got maybe a little late at
83. this dude Stephen graybach
got arrested and it was huge it was all
over the news
everybody had known about this guy but
those people I mentioned Keels and
a buddy from Mankato Minnesota
kind of went underground
when this guy got nailed because I
remember I was looking for Coke and
people were like dog things are bad the
Kingpin just got [__] nailed and the
the numbers were
they were unbelievable he was making six
million dollars every six weeks
he was bringing in tons from he was a
Jewish kid from Miami that moved to
Aspen he became a skier not a
professional he just skied he never even
saw the cocaine he just called it around
like where it was going his cocaine from
Miami went straight to Minneapolis and
the other half went to Hawaii he was
supplying Hawaii with Coke right from
that [__] spot in Aspen and nobody
nobody was [__] with this guy I mean
it was just like he would put money in
different has to after he got arrested
all the stories came out that the guy
was making so much money that he would
go to somebody like Mike that had a
restaurant and go Mike
I love your food here do you mind if I
get it safe and put it in the freezer
and pay your lease every month
and who would who wouldn't my lease is
eight thousand you sure you want yeah
I'll pay it every month just let me put
a safe in your freezer and then he would
run Dabs at those restaurants so he
would come in and go Mike his fifty
thousand dollars tell me when you need
more
and you're like fifty thousand dollars
you can eat in here for [__] ever
like you could eat here until [__] uh
Sun Gennaro day so
he was just no he was putting it in
restaurants and businesses to hide it
because he was making so much [__]
money when he got arrested this
[__] had
nine hundred thousand dollars in a
garbage can outside with leaves on top
of it
he had like 1.6 million cash in his
house and when they took him back to
Denver the DEA in Denver said no no no
no go back there there's more money we
got him on a wire and how they nailed
this [__] was through his
garbage they would pick up his garbage
and look at his measurements and all
that [__] they didn't find no cocaine
they didn't find a scale nothing they
couldn't tie him to cocaine you're like
Joey how does this tie into a [__]
bear it's coming [__] so now I
saw the [__] like I'm hearing all
these numbers and then in the middle of
that a heroin Kingpin died in Aspen he
was a Kingpin in Chicago I'm no this is
all like within a week or two and one
day people were like don't go on 82
that's the main road from Aston to
Glenwood Springs they'll all go on there
because there's a [__] funeral
some guys in the funeral getting seen
through from Aspen to Old Snowmass I
swear to God guys I did not see this
they had the guy was a black dude that
was filthy [__] Rich they had him up
in the car with hundred dollar bills in
his hands uh in the [__] casket and
[__] this is crazy so I'm saying what
the [__] goes on up in the [__] Aspen
and then to top it off an old Snowmass
right at the same time some guy there
was a huge story in the paper the feds
tapped some guy now wait you're like
Joey this is Aspen this is a small place
a DEA bust a drug the heroin Kingpin
from Chicago and now this story the
[__] feds were watching this guy this
coke dealer in Old Snowmass and they
wired you know like they went to the
[__] fuse box or whatever the [__] it
is and they wired him the only problem
was the feds [__] up with the wiring
so every time people would turn their TV
on he was coming on the TV guys you
can't write this [__]
you cannot write this [__]
he would come on the TV so his own
neighbors were calling them up going
Mike I could see you taking a shower
Mike you're over there eating breakfast
Mike you're eating dinner so he turned
around and
sued the feds for like millions of
dollars because they were programming
what was going on in his house to all
the other homes in the [__] area this
is crazy [__] and in the middle of all
this one day there's an article in the
paper in the Aspen Times
and it was like in the third page I
thought I was [__] hallucinating
all right I thought I was [__]
hallucinating there's this huge story
about
uh that they found these bears
or they found one let me not get this I
don't want people coming back at me
going up Joey was one bear okay they
found a bear
Dead next to a duffel bag next to
cocaine this was an aspen or a couple
miles away from Aspen guys the story for
cocaine bear happened in Atlanta Georgia
in the mountains of Georgia I think yeah
it's nothing to do with my story
but I still remember reading that and
then weeks later they had found three or
four more beds
and with that now for a word my
[__] sponsors this episode is
sponsored by better help if life came
with a user manual things would be easy
for everybody but they don't it doesn't
so when it's not working for you it's
normal to feel stuck I was stuck for a
long [__] time when I moved here
navigating the career change a new
relationship moving listen anything that
makes you feel uncertain is going to
make you feel a little creepy therapists
are trained to help you learn productive
coping skills which makes therapy the
closest thing you'll get to a user
manual for yourself listen I was with uh
I was a little confused after my move
somebody referred me to better help and
here I am two years later slinging dick
with three hands better help is online
therapy that offers your video phone and
chat therapy sessions if you don't want
to see anybody on Grandma you don't have
to as the world's largest therapy
service better help is match three
million people were professionally
licensed and vetted therapists available
100 online plus it's affordable and
guess what you're not going to find a
therapist that wants to see you in a
week with
better help they could take care of you
in three days just fill out a brief
question and to match you with a
therapist and if things ain't clicking
they could switch it to a new therapist
you couldn't be any simpler no waiting
rooms no traffic no endless searching
for the right therapist learn more and
save 10 off your first order at
betterhelp.com slash Diaz 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com Diaz
better help
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash Diaz thank
you for listening to the joints yeah so
they were [__] dead as disco by the
way
betterhelp.com [__] tremendous okay
and I'll tell you why in a second anyway
that is Disco This [__] these bears
and they had a big ride at the bottom
you know I I never [__] saw any of
these Bears I never hung out with these
bands I didn't know the people
who uh you know were drunk you know I'd
love to tell you I I knew the guys I was
in the bottom with flashlights you know
with [__] Flags to dump the coke it
wasn't me at all but that's guys when I
tell people like I did a podcast I
joined about two years ago
and I talked about the people that were
around me in Aspen
guys it was [__] weird and then I
left I was homeless I became an addict
the whole thing and I went back there I
ended up going back there like in the
October of 85 and guys when I went back
to Colorado
that was just a cocaine Factory
when I went back to [__] Snowmass
Village
in October of 85.
I wasn't doing coke I didn't snap till I
stayed and I spent two months before I
broke I made it through a year I think I
got high New Year's Eve 85 and then I
started getting high Miley but through
the ranks guys
there was some wild [__] going on up
there [__] that I think about now and
I'm like
what the [__]
you know I was just a plant I didn't
have any money I worked on a video store
you know I shoveled some snow I made
ends meet I did little hustles I hooked
people up with a pound of weed stupid
[__] like that but I was going day to
day pretty much so I wasn't even buying
that type of Coke but I was hearing this
[__] that was in the and then after June
when I was there June of 86 I said [__]
it my friend Danny who I got I owe him a
call I haven't spoken to this guy in
months called me and he says I got some
great Coke I want you to try and he came
out from Jersey and I tried it it was
fantastic and it was a thousand dollars
cheaper than what they were asking for
in Aspen
so I knew
even if I cut the price by 500
I was still making money hand over fist
I would be an idiot not to get involved
in it but once I got involved with that
cocaine batch and I started running in
those numbers and selling guns
guys I was hearing some wild [__]
the thing that I still cannot ever get
out of my mind like I think all my
stupid stories and all the crazy [__] I
did
you know I was going back East like
every other Wednesday every Wednesday
and picking up a quarter of a kilo and I
was bringing back guns and I would do
this
from [__] uh maybe September and I
did it to maybe December maybe August
August yeah a little like that because
it was the summer I started early and I
made some good money when I started
making money
and I started selling some coke people
started coming out of the [__]
woodwork at me
and that's when I started keeping the
guns and yeah some of it was the
paranoia from the cocaine I get that but
man
people started coming at me from all
directions to take
for me to stop getting the coke from
New York and for me to buy the coke from
them now here I am just a [__] ounce
dealer I you know I love again I love to
tell you I had [__] and helicopters
and I was just an ounce dealer and I if
I cut it with like seven grams it gave
me 35 I sold 30 grams I made some money
and I [__] uh snorted five [__]
grams of coke I wasn't doing nothing out
of this world but the people that were
approaching me was starting to get me a
guys and you know I'm not a scary cat I
was like these [__] people are not
you know every time I meet with somebody
who wanted to sell me Coke I would
notice a gun
and I go what the [__] you know in in
North Bergen and [__] for years I didn't
you know I hung out with Savages but
nobody really had a [__] gun on them
you know every time I might go to hug
these guys or shake their hand there was
always a gun or a knife
these guys are ready for [__] War but
the time that blew me away was that dude
kills his friend came up to him and then
he goes hey man
there's more to this story
when I came back in to LA to Colorado in
you know I I was a doorman I was
Security in a hotel and I was a a
Bellman you know like a Bellman I was
security and I had to make runs to the
airport at night
so Dan grabo got arrested in 80
December of 83
in that cocaine thing
when I got back to Aspen I didn't you
know what do you think I was thinking
about gray but what happened to him I
didn't know any I didn't know the guy
but when I got back I heard that he was
going to go on trial it was all over the
papers that there was no cocaine
involved that he was a Kingpin but he
was going to go on trial for money
laundering that's all they pinched him
on was the money logger okay
you know that talking about greybo again
it's not like I'm hanging out an aspen
jumping up and down I'm a poor [__]
house dealer in Snowmass Village I
wasn't going to those clubs up there I
knew about the Paragon and [__] like
that but that wasn't my cup of tea
and one [__] December like right
around the [__] holidays one night
you heard a bunch of ambulances
cops were coming you know you could hear
them on 82.
and the next day it was in the paper
they [__] put a car bomb
and grade both [__] car and blew him
the [__] up 24 days before his trial in
Denver
you could read this this is common
knowledge Dan graybo g-r-a-b-o-w
Dan grabo was at the Aspen Club lifting
weights like he did four or five nights
a week the Aspen Club is like they
charge you 20 bucks just to walk in
another hundred for a towel one of those
[__] places
every night when he left to work out and
he would get dressed and go out at night
but he would work out late and he would
give the valet 20 bucks to start his car
up 20 bucks to start his car up that
night the valet wasn't there
so he went out to start his [__] car
he had a regular Jeep they put a pipe
bomb under his [__] seat and bubble
the pipe bomb went right in his ass but
it was it was like the the De Niro movie
[__] uh
Casino the Jeep the year he had the jeep
had an extra metal plate underneath it
so it didn't really blow him up it blew
him up he lit on fire and he really bled
out he was alive after the car bomb he
made it to the hospital and he died at
the hospital
that didn't affect me I didn't know the
guy but what I didn't know is it
affected all the cocaine dealers around
the area
so now everybody moved up a notch
everybody was moving up a notch
everybody was scrambling to get Coke I
guessed Kelly and this guy were getting
Coke from this guy
so after he died like the smoke cleared
and that it was that summer when I
started dealing Coke so
again I didn't go to his wake I wasn't
involved with those people what had
happened was
I called kelly one day and she was like
listen man
uh I know you're paying a thousand
dollars I think at that time I was
paying I don't know 9 800
for 13 ounces or something like that
and she goes I'll tell you what if I can
make you the same deal would you stop
going to New York and buying our Coke
and now I'm like in demand like I'm like
oh [__] I'm living Miami Vice you know
what I'm saying people are calling me
like I'm like all right I can live with
this [__] and uh
I [__] uh
take the meeting guys again I've been in
some scary situations weapons
the guys call me and they go uh you know
go to a [__] uh pay phone and call us
so I went to the Snowmass Center there
and I called them and they will call you
but it was like real [__] Hush Hush
like you know and they will call you
back in like five minutes no names on
the phone all that [__] and I'm like
okay and they're like listen we'd like
to meet with you give us an address and
we'll pick you up
I'm like okay
and they [__] met me like a day later
or some [__] and I got in the car the
guys were cool how you doing nice to
meet you yeah but I I had a gun on me
you know I didn't know I'm not so right
away guys I had a gun on me
like that's never [__] good you know
I just shows you the people I was
running with and we drove to Woody Creek
somewhere and then they go listen can
you do us a favor and put a [__]
blindfold on and I'm like
are you [__] guys crazy
I put the blindfold down against my best
wishes
I get to the [__] place they search
me they take my gun they're very nice
Walk This Way follow us and when I get
in they go we gotta ask you another
favor do you mind putting a bag over
your head and I'm like what the [__] you
know I already got the things on my eyes
I can't see nothing like this guy these
guys that talk to you want to be very
secretive and I'm like oh here we go
back to [__] everybody's Miami Vice
weighing the Coke and putting it in a
thing and shaking it giving the money I
don't like none of that [__]
so they were like Joey you know we've
heard great things about you and we know
you're loyal blah blah blah you got all
this [__] and they're like we want you
to do business with us you know [__] it
and then they just started spilling
their [__] guts
you know talking about they got a
shipment every two weeks and it comes
right to them I wouldn't have to go
anywhere and then they go if you're
interested we'll let you [__] know
what to do the guys that drove here I
said I'm interested how much can you
pick up every two weeks I told them and
they go okay we're in business we'll
give you a call when we're ready go home
now thank you for coming like okay and
I'm like what the [__] I take the
bandage off they put blindfolds back on
me and now we drive like 10 minutes and
they go take it off and the guys are
like listen
when you hear this story this is when
you got to say to yourself because I
told this story on the church is [__]
you gotta ask yourself what the [__] was
going on on the way home
these [__] say to me listen
we don't give you the coke hand to hand
never you'll never see us again
what you need to do is join the Snowmass
club which was cousins with the Aspen
Club where they blew up greybo
I smell conspiracy do you smoke
conspiracy here
so the Aspen Club Snowmass Club you're
going to go to the Snowmass club and
join
and when you go there on certain days
we'll tell you what day to go there you
give the front counter girl
money and you go work out like you you
do all the time
but on the way out the Coco being your
locker
this is like [__] mind boggling like
this is like I'm like
am I living a [__] movie am I living
an episode of Miami Vice so
I tried to [__] go down there and
they're like oh how long do you want to
join for and I'm like you know eternally
I'm like I'm confused I don't know
nothing
and right and they're like
uh with the best package is to sign up
for the first year and I'm like oh great
give me the paperwork I'll sign up and
dog they were like do you want the
executive package or something I don't
even know what to say and they're like
it's like 1500 a year to join and they
need like 800 and I'm like what
like it was I don't even know if it was
1500 it was a number that was no because
you went down there was a gym but you
could play golf and you could steam bath
and you could smoke cigars with guys and
you could [__] you know you could
just do all this stupid [__] like it's a
whole day I was I was gonna go down
there lift some weights maybe [__]
swim a little bit and get the [__] out
of there pick up my Coke but when they
told me that like they're like no
you gotta go to the gym
give the girl the money and then go to
your locker work out and pick it you
cannot [__] just get the Coke and
leave
you got to go through a whole rigmarole
the whole [__] thing so so they're
like okay so I went down to the Joint I
couldn't afford to join I didn't want to
[__] join this gym
and they're like okay if you don't want
to join the gym you have to become a
volunteer so I became a volunteer
fireman
that's the reason I became a volunteer
fireman was to get the free subscription
so I could go in there and buy my
[__] cocaine listen guys I lasted as
a volunteer fireman
maybe a month and a half or two [__]
months I was never a volunteer for him
and I think I took the training and I
showed up for like two fives and I'm
like come on I'm gonna sit around with
eight fat guys putting on a dumpster
fire give me a break I'm getting my dick
sucked I'm snorting coke don't [__]
bother me if he dumpster flies at three
in the morning
so I [__] uh you know once it all
ended I got my car November of 86 and I
left I don't know what happened to the
Aspen Club I don't know whatever
happened to these people I don't know if
they lived or died it makes no
difference to me but it's just to show
you I tell you these things just to show
you
the [__]
this and I was just involved with like
little guys I can't even imagine what
the [__] was going up there but it was
everywhere when I tell you it was ever
and I think everybody was in on it
because there was a [__] thing that
if the cops the feds when they came to
town they stayed at the Red Roof Inn
there was no [__] Uber what's that
[__] now where you rent the house with
your buddies and nobody knows you're
there whatever the [__] that's called
you know Airbnb there wasn't none of
that so guys that was the main thing
they'd say when the feds come to town
they stay at the Red Roof Inn and you're
not allowed to sell Coke or anything
they were all tied in this was this was
the biggest conspiracy and I didn't even
touch I'm just telling you guys like the
different sizes of this [__] the Aspen
Club was [__] in bed with the
Snowmass Club how to you know and
probably the same owners I don't know go
on that website they're still open both
those clubs are still alive and kicking
[__] the Aspen Club Barbie Benton
used to be there she's a a Playboy chick
from the 80s I'll never forget I used to
date a girl she came home when they said
I took a shower with Barbie Benton and
he took a shower with my [__] because
you know after [__] working out
there's a general area bush look she
goes beautiful I'm like holy [__]
[Music]
[__] man so yeah I don't know much about
the cocaine bad
I don't know what's going on with it I
didn't write the [__] thing I'm just
telling you that when I lived in
snowman's Village
there was a bear that died from cocaine
no if you could look it up on the Aspen
Times I think the Aspen Times only goes
back 30 [__] years
so maybe you could fly I don't know
because I tried to get an article from
December 24th 1983 80
1983. I tried to get an article from
there years ago my buddy wrote for them
when he was a young guy like before he
became a writer he had an apprenticeship
over there so I asked him Mike Robuck if
he'd get the article he called and he
goes they they don't go back that far I
would love to get my hands on the
cocaine article
the night when I robbed them all on
Christmas Eve and wall gets burglarized
it's not Christmas Eve that's why I want
I wanted that article yeah I wanted that
article for the book or whatever the
[__] going on the book's going great
uh
all hands on deck I got to change a few
names all that [__]
which I [__] knew you know and the
last thing I want to talk about on a
beautiful Monday morning or something I
was going through last week you have
realizations in your life you know when
I did Beauty and the Beast with Felicia
you know for years
when you listen to different podcasts
Comics a lot of comics will go you know
what Joey Diaz always checks it you know
whether it's a text or a call I was
raised on checking it you know
and following up
you know
I try to do in a friendship but most
people don't do that's what you need to
do and that's what you need to do in all
your adventures you know
when my parents died my friends taught
me the greatest gift that you could
teach somebody which is the gift of
friendship there's no bigger gift than
friendship you know your family you're
stuck with them you know you can't pick
your [__] family when you look at
your mother and she's 100 pounds
overweight and she's got that wart
coming out of her face with the head
growing out of it and you're like how
the [__] is this will the Beast my
mother you can't you know what I'm
saying like you can't you can't [__]
you can't you know but when I learned
the value of a friend you know when I
when my parents died and what those
people did for me I really learned the
value of a friend so I respected
friendship I really did I respected it
more than most guys you know and I made
a lot of mistakes growing up but when I
realized I was alone in this world I
realized that friends are all you got
you know once your mom and your dad
leaves and your brother gets married to
a lesbian chick and the assistant gets
married to an organ grinder in Seattle
and you live in [__] New Jersey
you're not gonna see them you know so
once your parents are gone you realize
that you're alone in this [__] world
and that's a a horrible feeling you only
feel it for like two minutes and you're
like I'm alone you know I'm alone in
this world I got no umbilical cord
whatever the [__] they talking about
so you look at your friends a lot
different you know you look at your
brother your brother's great he's your
brother he's your blood but they got
their own life and they all got a
[__] nasty fat wife with a mole on
their face and you go to yourself why'd
he marry that [__] chick with them
but it doesn't matter you just lose so
what you really have in your life are
your friends
when I left North Bergen in 1985 I had a
handful of [__] friends
friends that I could breathe for and
friends that would Breathe to me they
had done it already I learned a
tremendous gift of friendship growing up
and I
respected friendship as much as I could
I'll never forget when I did that
beating the Beast with Felicia we had
gotten into a conversation
about people in LA and friends and how
you have to treat people
and she was like you do really well with
that I go because
I don't have a family
so I have to focus now you have
acquaintances you have friends and then
you have that little Inner Circle which
is your family without being your family
you know you tell your kids day your
uncle you know whatever they're your
[__] family the hell you breathe for
so my biggest accomplishment as a man
was keeping in touch with the people who
did me right as I was growing up
that was my main focus all those years
when I was in LA and that's what kept me
grounded the reason why I don't drive a
beamer and I don't say amazing and I
don't tell you that everything is
wonderful is because I stayed grounded I
kept on the phone with my friends and by
listening to what they were talking
about it made everything all right in my
world me living in Los Angeles was like
having a bad job
you you're doing it until you get to
your goal and then you don't have to
deal with these [__] people no more I
didn't know I was involved with these
type of people I just picked my friends
over them and I kept in touch with them
and whenever I came home we always try
to do a dinner or go out and I I was
telling Mike I took pride in that and
when I would come home there'd be like
six of us at dinner and I'd always go
hey man woman's because they say yeah I
haven't seen you and I go I live in
California
did you just say that you haven't seen
him since the last time I came here and
we did dinner like yeah but they lived
like [__] 10 miles apart and I'm like
how does this happen I would give a
[__] finger in L.A to be able to see
you guys once a week you know I would
give a [__] finger I'm stuck with all
these [__] fake people around me
so
you know when I every year I come here
and it'd be the same thing and I go
someday I'm going to move back and I'm
going to change all this [__] you
[__] are going to see each
other every weekend we're going to smoke
pot we're gonna do this well I moved
back
and coven was here at first you know and
when you call people they were concerned
about their parents you know it was the
beginning of covert when I moved here so
it didn't loosen up till after
I was here maybe for six months and then
I got the knee surgery I was stuck in
the house for three or four months and
at that time I was talking to my friends
and stuff like that and after the knee
surgery healed and you know things
slowed down a little bit I started doing
dinners with you know James and my other
buddies from North Barrington we started
doing little [__] dinners and stuff
like that but they were always few and
far like they were always
a month away
like it was a month and then we wouldn't
talk for another month and then we'd do
it again and then I hooked up with my
eighth grade friends and that's been
fantastic Louis Hernandez Dave Whitey
that's been [__] great but
everybody's got you know Whitey's mom
passed everybody's got their issues so
we get along we try to get together as
much as possible guys but it's not
it's just not [__] feasible you know
and it I was the how wrong was I because
I was the first guy that was saying when
I come back I'm gonna do all this [__]
when I come back I don't have two hours
I don't have an hour to drive up
somewhere sit for an hour and a half and
then come back I wish I had that like
the other day I was gonna go up to North
Bergen just to go to Rudy's and eat I
don't have that anymore I don't go up to
North Bergen like I used to but my point
is that
since I've been back here I've lost a
lot of contact with my friends there was
a couple friends that listened
40 years passed and we changed a ton in
40 years and I came back and we just
realized that we weren't the same people
and that's okay I could live with that
when I moved here the people I thought I
was going to see all the time
completely different than what happened
the friends that I still have from North
Bergen today are friends that
we built our relationship after I moved
here
and it wasn't about me being in a movie
it wasn't about me being stand up it was
that I knew them early on and they
wanted to come back in my life and I
wanted to be in their life
so last week I just had a rough week
friendship wise you know like just
coming to the conclusion that what that
was was that was a long [__] time ago
that was 40 [__] years ago Joey what
do you expect do you expect these for us
just to jump back in the saddle and yeah
it might happen once or twice a year and
you have to cherish it and but it was
just disappointing to me it just took a
little a lot of wind out of my sails
that it was a realization that uh
you try really hard to keep your friends
over the years and show like that but
life takes over and that's okay
that's okay it's not like we had an
argument or we disagreed on something we
talk we they we share our sentiments and
we move on and we try to put dates
together but
guys it's just you know with families
and kids and holloways and holidays and
jobs and [__] like that it just doesn't
work out so I just had to come to terms
that I was a little down for a few days
about it
but then I went to the [__] Festival
I got my little [__] blue belt and
here we are on a Monday morning ready to
sling dick we got what we got 20 [__]
shoplifting days left that's it
Christmas is right around the [__]
corner
so that's what's going on right now I've
been having a great time thank you for
all you guys that are helping me out
with uh
Stoner club they're doing [__] great
uh thank you they got great [__]
reefer I just got it delivered from them
the other day dog they gave me some I
don't know what the [__] it was
something in a bag on the top over the
top holy [__] it was over the [__]
thumb and I'm trying to get them some uh
some laughing gas people are really
[__] digging the laughing gas so I'm
happy but remember Stoners Club they
have just go to the website just go to
the website I don't remember all the
specials they got but I'll tell you what
I'm gonna do for you just pressing Uncle
Joey 10 and I'm gonna give you 10 off
for [__] life Mike that was a great
video last week the way he took it off
the shirt great [__] job and that's
what's going on we got to wait a whole
[__] month to do a show the 28th and
uh we're working on the book we're
healthy and we're slinging dick guys
listen try to be a good friend but
always know that
after a while there's nothing you could
do we [__] change we really do change
and we change our perspectives and what
we watch and what we listen to and
that's life guys we keep [__]
evolving I love you [__] with
all my heart have a great week and now
for a word for my [__] sponsor
Jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you for taking my here beating today I
had a good time this episode is
sponsored by Better Health listen if
life came with a user manual it would be
a lot easy for everybody but it doesn't
so when it's not working for you it's
normal to feel stuck navigating a career
change you're moving kids listen it
makes you feel uncertain I get you
therapists are trained to help you learn
productive coping skills which makes
therapy the closest thing you'll get to
a user manual listen I was stuck when I
moved here I was just you know I didn't
have an answer but Dana I better help
put it together for me better help is
online therapy that offers video phone
and chat sessions you can choose not to
see anybody or you could see somebody as
the world's largest therapy service
better help has matched three million
people and I'm one of them with
professionally licensed and better
therapists available 100 online plus
it's affordable just fill out a brief
questionnaire and we'll match you with a
therapist and if things ain't clicking
you could easily switch to a new
therapist it couldn't be any easier no
waiting rooms no traffic no endless
searching for the right therapist go to
betterhelp.com right now learn more and
save 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com Diaz again that's
betterhelp.com
Diaz and this Saturday [__] get
ready for UFC 282 you're gonna get paid
laid and pod laid with DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
partner of the UFC they got a deal
that's going to make your [__]
[__] ass fly out of the [__]
Spectrum this Saturday new customers can
bet just five dollars on a pre-fight
money line on any fighter to win and get
150 and free bets when they do I'm
watching Darren till and I'm definitely
watching Bryce Mitchell this weekend but
right now everybody could earn up to 50
boost when you place the same game
parlay on UFC 282 download the app right
now use promo code Joey bet five dollars
this weekend money line on any fight of
the win and get 150 if they do that's
code Joey this Saturday at DraftKings
Sportsbook the official sports betting
part in the UFC but it don't stop there
we got Monday Night Football tonight so
download the DraftKings Sportsbook app
and to code Joey and let's get this
party started I want to thank DraftKings
I want to thank betterhelp.com but most
importantly I want to thank you guys
I'll see you Wednesday Thursday morning
Tip Top [__] Magoo love you
[Music]